when Jennifer Lawrence came on your show
oh yeah yeah yeah and she turns to you
and says oh my god when you were the
head riter at Saturday Night Live I had
such a massive crush on you does that
enter your mind at least once a week or
have you you just have no time for it I
just don't have a time for I was very I
should stress I was very flattered and U
my wife was so happy she was just what
I'm so happy jener Lawrence told you
that story I'm so glad that you have
that in your back pocket every single
day um you know the really funny thing
is now one I I was engaged so obviously
I don't I would never have like a flirt
radar up but I never I feel like when I
worked at SNL I never had the bandwidth
to flirt with anyone and so many even
before I you know even when I was single
like so many of the most Charming uh you
know beautiful
intelligent uh women came through that
show and I you know I also feel like I
was always like filthy and uh sweaty and
stressed and uh uh so it really I I I
mostly just think it reflects poorly on
Jennifer Lawrence's taste
that